j'ai eu envie de faire un quiz sur
l'environnement alors oui c'est ça c'est
toi qui vas répond sur la nature les
animaux j'ai envie de dire sur l'a10
avec un grand v et comme le nom de votre
émission c'est sur le front
j'ai fait faire alors c'est un filtre
stram gram installable qu'on a pu faire
juste pour notre émission pour l'instant
n'existe pas qu'à chaque fois que j'en
vois des gens qui vont s'afficher sur
mon front et j'ai devoir dire du bien 2
half accor ac ci répond bien malin qui
répond pas bien voilà je bien forcément
faux du vrai dire du bien à dire que du
bien
alors dès que vous aurez une bonne
réponse donc j'irai du alors première
question et vous jouez avec nous chez
vous lequel de ces aliments nécessite le
plus d'eau pour sa production doc gynéco
boeuf le café ou le chocolat alors le
boeuf demande beaucoup de dos mais je
crois que c'est pas ce qui demande le
plus de ces quinze mille litres d'eau
pour 1 kilo je crois que c'est le
chocolat qui est le plus grand malheur
donc je vais te le dire déjà bravo ici
non il parle
quinze mille litres d'eau pour produire
un kilo de viande de boeuf déjà bonnes
réponses et plus de 17 mille litres
d'eau pour faire un kilo de chocolat
très bonne
alors il faut que tu as fait pour que ça
tourne déjà plus beaucoup ça tombe
direct avait alors oui j'ai pris une
tôle gaza d'accord il ça va tourner
merde
michel cymes alors michel cymes à six
mois je vais dire du bien de michel
cymes je vais vous dire michel cymes
s'éteint c'est un excellent médecin
voilà je sache si demain j'ai été malade
le premier médecin j'irai voir après mon
père ça michel cymes séjour s est sûre
c'est sûr et certain
voilà un excellent médecin bravo pour
tout ce que tu fais pour la médecine
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est pas un animateur c'est super
le men sûrs superbe c'est que ça est un
oiseau qui est la capacité d'imiter le
bruit d'une tronçonneuse
ces mots de voler en arrière de voler
comme carlos ghosn ou de s'auto
reproduire ce que tu le connais mr ouai
je j'hésite entre le a et le b mais
voler en arrière ça m'étonnerait pour un
oiseau donc je dirais ça c'est michael
jackson qui a invité le bruit d'une
tronçonneuse un peu comme les marteaux
piqueurs
alors on la peine l'oiseau vacarme
regardez le sens paray
[Applaudissements]
la célèbre aiguille
quel très attention à merde qui revient
moins cher il va bien ça va toi sinon je
te fais c'est la croix et produire et ça
continue on va voir des choses qu'on ne
veut pas aller attention c'est bien de
[Musique]
[Rires]
viser du bien de yann est ce qu'on peut
demander un hugo attend maintenant huit
ans et demi je veux dire du je vais dire
du bien de lui déjà il était excellent
quand il était sur canal+ vraiment bravo
yann et ça non mais franchement j'ai
rien contre yann barthès je sais pas
j'ai rien contre lui on se connaît pas
du tout si on s'est vus on sait la doule
voir deux fois dans notre vie donc voilà
on n'a pas de ya pas de n'y a pas
d'embrouillé kmart est donc ça va voilà
je lui fais des bisous et voilà et puis
ici venir un jour avec hugo clément
hugot clément bien dans l'émission il
peut venir indique t on invitait aussi
un jour un même chez castaldi et bondir
sur une poubelle
je voulais me demander s'il n'était plus
proche
yann barthès ou de vous hugo créances
qui la travaillent avec les deux donc
avec timone n'ont hélas pas travailler
on mange des noix de cajou ensemble
comme j'ai dit à sir i la dernière fois
je ne je ne m'exprime pas sur ce sujet
voilà qui n'est pas je ne veux pas
participer à créer des dissensions il ya
dix ans sur j'aime la paix et l'unité
donc je ne fais pas parler d'eux s'est
dit lui c'est papa et maman voilà c'est
tout voilà un mouton risque de mourir si
il n'est pas tondu si on le castres s'il
se voit dans un miroir ou s'il se fait
peloter moutons à cause de l'élevage de
l'homme risquent de mourir me de mourir
s'il n'est pas temps du passé il ya
quelques siècles les moutons perdre
leurs poils naturellement et comme en a
sélectionné que les moutons qui
produisait le plus de laine pour les
besoins de l'industrie ben maintenant
ils ont besoin d'être tondus sinon il
meurt pas toutes les races mais
certaines mais c'était pas nécessaire
quand loeb ne fait pas des moutons parce
que ça continue de pousser et qu'au
moment des parasites développe et voilà
ça je crois pas qu ils meurent parce
qu'il faille qui y sont tellement bons
c'est qu'ils perdent tombe sur le dos je
n'ai plus la force un peu plus qu'on
attend ça en général avancé en général
hier et des parasites s'est aussi
développée
est-ce qu'on peut tomber deux fois sur
le même ou pas non non pas tomber dans
la même veine dire alors yaki c'est une
amie c'est rien ça l'avait dit du bien
leur nom mais alors mais seriez city
c'était une très bonne amie mais oui
carrément
et depuis qu'elle est sur tf1 j'ai plus
de nouvelles écoutes et comme la plupart
des gens qui vont sur tf1 on dirait
qu'ils sont sûrs kolontar
quand ils m'ont sur tf1 mon frère on les
voit plus donc voilà donc je vais vous
dire que j'ai rien contre elle ma chérie
je t'aime bien si on était très très
paquin valérie damidot et moi petit je
me rappelle m'être de son numéro parker
qui s'appelle on dirait que c est ce qu
on était très très très amis la mise à
jour mais la salle et sanitaire des
choses positives alors on vous écoute
battu à l'usure du bio en direct
voilà je suis en rigole encore sont en
berne
si je me suis revel son numéro par coeur
bravo ouais mais attendez
valérie damidot elles dopées par le
maire alain sahel va dire ça sarah prix
qui ont qu'il va me virer un truc comme
ça
attention deuxième sonnerie je rappelle
que valérie damidot joue pour une
décoration de congé ces bons ne marche
pas c'est pas laisser un petit message
valérie damidot c'est cyril hanouna et a
mon numéro qui s'est fâché ma chérie et
qui s'y afficher ma chérie on avec hugo
clément vous voulez dire du bien de toi
on voulait dire que conté mais avant
c'est bien ça on aime quoi tu fais de la
déco qu'on aime croquer avec des chats
voilà on aime on aime on aime ta
personne voilà donc rappelle moi quand
tu veux ma chérie d'accord on s'en va
elles rappellent elles sont restées
blanches la question le lézard basilique
est surnommé le lézard jésus-christ car
il peut changer l'eau en vin il peut
marcher sur l'eau il ne vit qu'à
nazareth où il se fait régulièrement
insulter sur france inter de se tromper
quand même la wii party sur madère la
bergerie peut marcher sur l'eau c'est le
lézard basilique à ce qu'ils avaient spa
culte dessous ouais mais merci on vous
appellera semaine prochaine certainement
le secret du lézard basilique se trouve
dans sa foulée
l'enfoncement la la pac en fait l'enfant
de sa patte créer une poche d'air
et c'est ça ou pas c'est un truc de ouf
moi j'aimerais bien est un lézard
basique ah oui tu marches comme sat avec
une meuf comme ça s'est classé sur une
barque comme ça tu pe dit je pars de la
barre qui tu cherches tu reviens sans
déconner c'est déjà fait sa barque avec
un amoureux benhaim oui à la paix avant
c'est le gros truc quand elle quand tu
voulais pécho une meuf tulasne et faire
de la barque même pas tout à fait c'est
romantique c'est agréable c'est sympa
voilà alain la barque donc franchement
c'est un truc de vieux salamé proulx est
tout petit dit claude odon mais si on
rigolait bien les premiers petits avant
la mi temps un petit trou non mais ça tu
as des belles cas des gens qui sont
normales est un petit c'est la pagaille
bah ouais vous attend le montant levé le
voile à circoncise et merci à
l'allemagne - chéri alex en longueur
mais pas dire du bien à tout le monde en
nocturne perché avec celles entendues
dit on arrête je